bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du statut de culture et
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi
14 mars
quarante sept artistes et une centaine
d'oeuvres depuis le 10 mars voisins le
bretonneux annoncé sa huitième biennale
de la sculpture une exposition pour
découvrir tous les styles et les
techniques
saurons-nous humains demain du 17 au 25
mars le théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mail art et
science pour se questionner c'est la
deuxième édition des rencontres i cité
et les échos les trappistes vont partir
en finlande ou presque la pms qu
organise demain des concerts
pédagogiques autour de l'oeuvre de jean
sibelius un compositeur finlandais
acrobates rois mages ou ours depuis le
10 mars et la 8e édition de la biennale
de la sculpture de voisins-le-bretonneux
près de 100 oeuvres sont exposées à la
maison de coville
[Musique]
on
une certaine douceur qui mène à la
contemplation une acrobate suspendu qui
regarde un ours en équilibre pour sa
huitième édition voisins le bretonneux a
sélectionné 47 artistes venus de toute
la france
c'est une biennale qui est ouverte à
tout le monde en fait il n'ya pas de ce
n'est pas réservé aux visites noah nous
avons souhaité l'ouvrir justement il ya
quelques années pour pouvoir avoir un
plus grand nombre d'oeuvres une plus
grande variété une certaine émulation
[Musique]
tous les styles toutes les techniques du
textile au bronze plus d'une centaine d'
inventions exposé à la maison de covile
c'est beaucoup plus simple d'aller vers
des expos de peinture
il y en a à peu près partout la
sculpture c'est un art nettement plus
méconnu donc le fait de faire une
biennale de faire venir à voisin
quantité une quantité d'artistes variés
impressionnante
voilà c'est bien parce que les gens vont
vous découvrir des choses qui lui
généralement n'ont pas l'occasion
d'aller voir
un public qui pourra aussi faire
connaître son coup de coeur un prix sera
remis le 25 mars
la biennale reviendra dans deux ans
[Musique]
à elancourt c'est la photographie qui
s'expose le club de l'image en boîte a
investi la galerie de la ferme du
mousseau des passionnés qui se sont
penchés sur un thème la métamorphose
leur vision est à découvrir jusqu'au 22
avril les images font signer quentin le
frère métamorphose un mot simple en
apparence métamorphose du temps qui
passe de l'objet de la personne 17 des
adhérents du photo club élan courtois se
sont prêtés au jeu
on se donne un mois chacun moi on
s'essaye c'est pas toujours évident à
mes tableaux ça nous a paru bien
compliqué aux deux le le mot laisse
voyager l'esprit et l'imagination mais
c'est toujours un peu compliqué après de
remettre des photos fixes dessus et bon
bah ça on l'a laissé sa mue rire pendant
un an à peu près lors des pit revient de
temps en temps et puis dans les sas
étaient comptés dans l'année dernière un
an de travail oulaï des photographes
amateurs et passionnés s'est posé des
clichés singulier classées par
thématiques ou les éléments attirent
l'oeil et ressorte au propre comme au
figuré
le principe consistant à remettre en
relief donc à revenir vers l'objet de
l'image à plat revenir vers l'objet et
des choses sur sur la monstre on
constate dans la nature ce qu'on voit
dans la nature simplement les
transformations de matériaux des choses
sur la façon dont les gens ont pu dire
ça peut prier des matériaux exotiques et
puis beaucoup de choses sur les reflets
c'est assez c'est assez facilement un
esprit 17 points de vue qui donne à voir
ce qui peut échapper à notre oeil pour
que le regard lui aussi se
métamorphosent rencontré une cité
deuxième édition du 17 au 25 mars
yolaine masse est à vous est à l'origine
de ces rencontres et cette année les
arts et les sciences vont chercher à
répondre à un thème une main de mots en
effet son thème particulièrement actuel
en fait les thèmes sont déterminés en
général deux ans quasiment deux ans à
l'avance pas s'il ya tout un travail
bibliographique et tout un travail de
conception du projet mais on ne savait
pas que on tomberait en plein dans cette
danse est vague consacré notamment à
l'intelligence artificielle même si on
ne va pas parler que de ça humains
demain c'est pas uniquement
l'intelligence artificielle l'homme
augmenté le transhumanisme s'est aussi
essayé de définir ce qu'est l'homme
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai quand on
tombe en plein dans le dans le rendu du
rapport de cédric villani sur
l'intelligence artificielle donc c'est
assez basses et surtout que l'idée est
surtout de pouvoir s'arrêter sur un
thème j'ai l'impression que certainement
à travers même les projets artistiques
la programmation on effleure un certain
nombre de thèmes et on a envie à
certains moments et c'est le cas pendant
cette grosse semaine de s'appesantir et
de creuser de données voilà de donner
des outils de donner à comprendre ces
rencontres une cité c'est comme un
instrument un outil de partage du savoir
et pour partager le savoir un avis des
scientifiques des artistes scientifiques
d un test qu'il n'y a pas que des rendez
vous artistique il y en a sept quand
même dans la programmation mais vous
proposer aussi des tables rondes des
cafés des sciences à des projections
vous allez dans les salles obscures
ouais enfin dans les salles obscures
avec notamment en partenariat avec l ugc
skywest oui l'idée c'était de pouvoir
éclairer
une thématique scientifique ou pas mais
enfin d'éclairer une thématique par le
regard des scientifiques des chercheurs
toutes disciplines scientifiques
confondues le regard des artistes et le
regard des réalisateurs qui sont
eux-mêmes des artistes et on voit
souvent que les artistes ont parfois
anticiper un certain nombre de
recherches qui ont lieu aujourd'hui donc
c'est assez assez intéressant de
confronter ces trois points de vue vous
avez conçu le programme avec alexei
grinbaum alors il est chercheur au
laboratoire philosophie des sciences au
cea de saclay on les écoute il était
l'invité d'un vip il ya un mois ce
message est le suivant on ne peut pas
vraiment aujourd'hui penser le moins
juste avec de la biologie ou de
neurosciences le main se définit par
rapport aussi aux objets qui l'entourent
et ces objets sont numérique
informatique aujourd'hui en grande
partie il ya des algorithmes partout
l'homme fonctionne dans un monde dans un
contexte et pour penser le main et ne
suffit pas de penser son corps
biologique
il faut penser aussi sa condition par
rapport au numérique
c'est une pensée qu'on retrouve dans
l'art justement c'est une pensée quand
oui c'est une saisine conséquent on
retrouve dans l'art enfin on va le voir
dans les différents dans les différents
spectacles ya des approches qui peuvent
être des approches en civil et des
approches qui sont des approches
intellectuelle on essaie de comprendre
l'homme dans sa globalité pas uniquement
par son cerveau est le principe même de
l'art c'est de mettre le corps en avant
et de travailler sur ce sur ce corps là
mais là en écoutant alexei grinbaum je
me dis que j'ai eu beaucoup de chance de
pouvoir travailler avec lui pendant un
an pour préparer pour concevoir ces
rencontres on a absolument besoin
en tout cas moi c'est ce que je défende
une caution scientifique et alexei est
un spécialiste de l'éthique des
nouvelles technologies spécialiste de
l'information quantique et pendant prés
donnant il m'a guidée tous les quinze
jours toutes les trois semaines on se
voyait on faisait un point on précisé la
pensée il valider ou invalider certaines
de mes intuitions certaines de mes
hypothèses et c'est très très agréable
de travailler avec je sais pas si on
peut dire avec des sachants en tout cas
avec des cherchant avec des personnes
qui se questionnent sur absolument tous
et leur présence et
dispensés sont souvent des spécialistes
et est-ce qu'il faut chercher aussi à
vulgariser cette pensée de l'époque qui
nous concerne aussi on se rend compte de
deux choses d'une part qu'il y à une
vraie demande de la part des publics de
la part des citoyens de d'essayer de
comprendre un certain nombre de choses
dont on parle on parle tout le temps
d'intelligence artificielle de 2,2
d'hommes augmenté mais qu'est ce que
c'est exactement nous ce qu'on veut
donner c'est ce qu'on dira c'est sortir
des débats caricaturaux blanc et noir et
donner de la matière ça veut pas dire
que autour au cours de cette semaine
tout sera pensé tout sera dit mais en
tout cas on aura donné la principale
matière qui permettra ensuite aux
spectateurs qui sont aussi des citoyens
nous sommes également des citoyens de
s'emparer de cette matière est d'avoir
tout simplement une réflexion voilà on
veut comment redevient ton citoyens
seraient en partant de sujets qui
pourraient être monopolisée par la
science ou par l'industrie des nouvelles
technologies et découvrir peut-être un
certain avant gardisme parce que souvent
les artistes ou les scientifiques
découvrent bien pu temps c'est surtout
découvrir le présent en fait parce qu'un
certain nombre de choses dont on va
parler qui existe déjà depuis depuis
bien longtemps et la deuxième chose que
je voulais dire c'est que vous parliez
de vulgarisation 100 % des chercheurs
des invités qui seront présents lors de
ces rencontres sont des gens qui veulent
partager ce savoir là et qui ont besoin
de s'adresser à d'autres personnes que
les personnes qu'il croise soit dans les
colloques spécialisés ou dans les
laboratoires ça c'est très important
pour eux on a beaucoup parlé de l'aspect
science sur l'aspect spectacle ce que
vous êtes tertiales coeur de métier et
le spectacle qui ouvre la semaine et la
réflexion c'est sans objet d'aurélien
bory un face à face avec un robot et
avant d'en parler je vous propose de
regarder un extrait
[Musique]
on
lens est une création qui crée une
relation entre l'homme et la machine
mais en regardant les images je vous dis
d'une part c'est un spectacle magnifique
mais vous ne serez pas surpris que je
dise et d'autre part qu'ils symbolisent
vraiment notre rapport à la machine à
savoir un rapport de défiance dans un
premier temps et puis un rapport
d'apprivoisement mutuelle gem on peut si
on peut dire mutuel mais en tout cas
l'objectif et c'est finalement ce qu'on
défend dans ces rencontres une cité
c'est l'objectif c'est d'arriver à
maîtriser cette technologie à se les
approprier ne pas être dominée par l oms
ne pas être perdu sa touche l'industrie
automobile et a une petite peur de
pertes
perso c'est aller tout donc de remettre
ça d'avoir cette relation on voit qu'il
faut ils font corps avec la machine
ils font corps avec la machine et puis
au fil amouroux au fur et à mesure du
spectacle cette machine s'humanise c'est
étonnant c'est étonnant ce que l'on ce
que l'on ressent c'est à dire que la
machine à de la sensualité ou fur et à
mesure que l'humain l'apprivoiser se
l'approprier 7 700 d'humanisation et un
autre spectacle la développe ces soft
lave et là on parle d'intelligence
artificielle c'est un peu plus loin
c'est une une indignation à l'envers
puisque c'est l'histoire d'une
intelligence artificielle d'un assistant
personnel
on va se dire quand vous ce qu'on se
projette quelques années devant nous
et cette intelligence artificielle cet
assistant personnel va s'attacher à sa
propriétaire ou à sa maîtresse chez pas
comment il faut la définir et et nous
mêmes on va s'attacher à cette
intelligence artificielle qui est ça
c'est la fin du spectacle va devoir être
habilité et qui va forcément mourir pour
donner naissance à une nouvelle
intelligence artificielle c'est
magnifique de la façon dont tu fais des
liasses appris la problématique et le
sujet à l'envers merci le même assez
merci à vous alors les rencontres incité
débute samedi 17 mars et toute la
programmation est bien sûr à retrouver
sur le site internet du théâtre un goût
de danse à présent avec la rencontre
d'une compagnie yvelinoise les melting
urban coup les danseurs ont entre 14 et
17 ans est une pratique le hip hop
regarder répéter encore et encore
inlassablement un quotidien pour ces
jeunes yvelinois depuis quatre ans il
forme le melting urban coup une
compagnie de jeunes danseurs
sélectionnés sur audition
une compagnie récent créé par aurélie
aldebert leur chorégraphe et professeur
de hip hop ça c'est pas par terre et
eléonore ça sera au pire s'il vous plaît
le tout premier objectif de cette
compagnie c'était de permettre à des
jeunes de monter sur scène et
et de et de montrer ce qu'ils avaient
dans le ventre et ce qu'ils avaient
envie de monter sur scène et de partager
des scènes vraiment avec d'autres
groupes que ce soit des groupes hip hop
mais voir aussi s'ouvrir sur d'autres
styles de danse comme la danse classique
le moderne le jazz le contemporain
dix jeunes de 14 à 17 ans qui ont fait
de la danse un loisir quasi
professionnelle deux à trois
entraînements hebdomadaires et des
stages il jongle leur passion avec leur
quotidien de collégiens et lycéens
on s'est fait là on a des trainings 1h30
technique et trois heures en compagnie
heureusement fin heureusement c'est le
samedi les training company mais c'est
assez compliqué parce que justement 17
ans en terminale j'ai le bac et le
travail voilà mes origines ou des
toujours de que c'est d'abord l'école et
ensuite la danse jusqu'il toujours en
fait parce que je suis très compétitive
donc faire que du loisir je pense ça me
manquerait quelque chose donc travailler
beaucoup ça j'aime bien debasement elle
a dansé une passion j'ai envie d'en
faire mon métier plus tard
du coup pour moi c'est pas du tout une
contrainte est de pouvoir entrer dans
une compagnie aussi jeune
c'était un rêve de petite fille ce
samedi ils passent un nouveau concours
des rendez-vous qu'il présente une à
deux fois par mois
cette fois ils sont aux scènes urbaines
gini cypher on a fait un concours
chorégraphique parce que ça donne un
challenge pour les compagnies mais avant
tout c'est le plaisir de monter sur
scène c'est le plaisir de voilà ont créé
une chorégraphie ont créé un show et on
le présente devant la famille devant les
amis
non
bah un petit peu stressé mais
ça va c'est de l'adrénaline positif donc
non là c'est on est motivé pour donner
le meilleur de nous-mêmes et va faire
kiffer public en fait huit groupes sont
en compétition pour la catégorie junior
les melting urban cruiser les troisièmes
à se présenter sur scène
[Musique]
pour cette deuxième édition il termine
3e prochain objectif la finale de haut
sauf crew pro le 17 mars prochain avec
dans le viseur le mois de mai les
qualifications du hip hop international
france à orléans pour tenter de partir à
las vegas de nouveaux invités nous ont
rejoints en plateau marianne piketty
bonjour bonjour vous êtes la directrice
artistique de la paix m excuse et
violoniste et hervé fardoux bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président de la bm
sql en rappel c'est l'association pour
la promotion de la musique à 50 millions
et votre actualité c'est des journées
deux concerts c'est demain et vendredi
des mouvements pédagogiques avec les
écoliers de 51 ans n'est pas trappistes
comme je l'annonçais tout à l'heure tout
à fait eh bien il ya des trappistes mais
effectivement donc ça c'est un lieu à la
brise et devant le succès l'an dernier
on a monté de deux journées successives
et on va accueillir en fait 4000
personnes de tout des douze communes
sauf deux qui étaient un peu éloigné
mais voilà on va boire donc énormément
de monde et c'est très intéressant ça
permet aux enfants de découvrir
est ce un côté saint quentinois sait on
est vraiment des associations pour
répondre sur la musique à 50 ans divine
est donc c'est un projet voilà
excessivement saint quentinois alors
marianne pourra plus parler du côté
artistique projet voilà mais
effectivement on est très très contents
de cette réussite on à en préparer un
dossier très très fournie sur alors ça
va être le concerto de sibelius
donc effectivement c'est pas pire et de
luz et sibelius et on a préparé un
dossier notamment sur la finlande sur le
rapprochement entre l'histoire de la
finlande sibelius qui en fait créé un
peu le
comment dire l'hymne de la finlande mois
qui va fêter cette année son centenaire
s'arrête et on aura en entrevue après on
aura donc un événement spécial après
pour le concert du samedi c'est lui
justement joué le concerto pour violon
et orchestre de jean sibelius
il est écrit roux 904 j'ai vu que
c'était une des oeuvres de mieux écrites
pour le jeu violeau c'est c'est le cas
alors j'avais peur qu'il dit c'est que
dès qu'on monte sur scène il fallait
considérer qu'il est vrai que l'on joué
c'était la plus belle
un festival ya des gens qui disent que
ce concerto et est très bon
personnellement j'aime trop la musique
dans sa globalité pour beethoven
chostakovitch ou à bartok
donc je pense que ça serait voilà ceci
dit si mais lui c'est peut-être moins
connu et ce qui moi ce qui me touche et
qui qui qui montrent que ça fait 17 ans
qu'on existe et qu au bout de 17 ans on
peut on peut avoir cette demande parce
que c'est pas nous qui sommes allés
chercher c'est 90 l'enfance à 58 6 1 en
deux jours les quatre concerts par jour
donc ces huit concerts et l'idée c'est
vraiment centré sur le concerto de
sibelius parce que finalement maintenant
les enfants ils arrivent au concert on
leur dit vous connaissez leurs caisses
bah oui nono ils connaissent leur casser
maintenant croiser les clés seuls
connaissent devrait plus besoin donc
maintenant on entraîne l'oreille pour
leur faire entrer dans une oeuvre
ambitieuse parce que c'est une très
belle oeuvre mais c'est une oeuvre
ambitieuse et et donc l'idée du du
pédagogique c'est ces deux
justement ce début qu'est-ce que ça
évoque ce thème vise à échanger avec eux
comment ça se passe le vrai découper ou
la jouer dans son entier alors en fait
le vrai des l'idée c'est quand même
aiguisé l'oreille parce que pour
profiter comme toute chose pour profiter
d'un mais d'un bon mais culinaire si on
fait tout mélanger ça marche pas et que
si on mélange tout mais quand on connaît
le goût voilà qu'on a donc l'idée c'est
la même chose pour l'oreille c'est
d'avoir une oreille développer une
oreille analytique qui permet d'avoir
une accès à la musique qui est
différente
est ce que l'on sait c'est qu'on parlait
l'huma c'est que le cerveau en fait chez
les enfants est en plein développement
et quand on atteint un enfant qui accès
à ça eh bien il n'entendra jamais plus
la musique comme quelqu'un qui n'a pas
exactement
donc l'idée c'est 'qui le pédagogique
est organisé entre des moments où on les
fait rentrer vraiment entendre la
clarinette le dialogue clarinette basson
mais aussi développer un imaginaire ce
tapis sonore donc la finlande et voilà
ce violon qui rendent sur ce tapis
sonore qu'est ce que ça représente
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être moi même
j'ai un imaginaire donc je vais leur
parler un peu de morale et donner le
vôtre mais
voir voilà c'est à dire actifs ce qui
est génial dans cette dans la musique
classique qui n'est pas de l'opéra c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de mots donc en fait on
peut ce qu'ils veulent exactement
exact c'est le principe un peu aussi de
la paix mais ce que vous mettez en avant
la musique classique n'est pas
nécessairement un art très accessible à
cette tranche d'âge tout à fait tout à
fait et mais en même temps c'est à cet
âge là ils n'ont aucun a priori ils ont
donc ça ne compterait moins sur le pré
penser ils sont très ouverts quand monte
notamment donc nos opéras parce que là
ils vont écouter un concert on va voir
en revanche là ils vont chanter on a on
à 290 enfants ce moment qui est en train
de travailler sur un projet qui va
donner le 16 juin au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ils
découvrirent est en fait pour eux ça ne
pose aucun problème il n'a aucun a
priori
et ça c'est en école élémentaire dès
qu'on arrive en collège c'est un peu
plus compliqué et puis alors l'intérêt
c'est que ça se fait entre à plusieurs
peut dire que voilà serre que un coeur
c'est pas une succession de voix un
orchestre et sa mariée c'est justement
vous allez il sera accompagné de
l'ensemble
orchestral partant de là le dieu qui est
tout jeune en qui est écrit en 2017 si
je me trompe pas cette une est érigée
par julien masmondet d'être accompagnées
aussi par plusieurs musiciens fait la
paix m excuse c'est un progrès projet
excessivement large mais qui à son sens
est l'une des choses c'est que on s'est
dit parce que on si on est acteur de
voilà par rapport aux jeunes aussi aux
jeunes musiciens
donc on a eu dans l'idée de former un
orchestre spécialement pour l'action de
la pms qu est ce qui vous rassurent
envers les capacités les possibilités de
jouer certains certaines oeuvres
absolument et puis aussi pour créer de
l'emploi pour faire un lien avec entre
les solistes beaucoup plus connues
certaines personnes les solistes qui
sont dans l'ensemble orchestral nous les
retrouverons sur des saisons sur la
saison de musique de chambre dans tout
ça fait un lien et
et tout ce genre sera à découvrir en
vous coupez le temps nous file nous
prend de court parce que l'idée en plus
vous le faites pour les enfants mais les
enfants pourront amener leurs parents au
concert puisque vous le jouez le samedi
17 mars et le soir c'est à 20h30
merci abîmée est revenue en plateau donc
les concerts de pédagogique ces jeudi et
vendredi mais surtout n'oubliez pas le
rendez vous à vivre en famille à la
merise attrape et à 20h trouve qu'il est
maintenant nous ne pas justine henin
[Musique]
que voir dans les salles ce week-end
l'ubo quand vous donne son coup de coeur
on les écoute alors le coup coeur du
ciné cette semaine c'est la forme de
l'eau le très beau et très réussie conte
horrifique de guillermo del toro ultra
récompensé aux oscars bafta golden
globes
voilà donc un très beau film un conte
fantastique comme il a l'habitude après
le labyrinthe de pan auquel le film pour
de certaines manières faire référence
donc c'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille
qui travaille dans un laboratoire ultra
secret je pas vous raconter grand chose
mais et qui va tomber amoureuse de la
forme de l'eau et comme le dit guillermo
del toro ça résumait c'est bien son film
l'eau est un élément très puissant un
peu comme l'amour
donc c'est un conte horrifique mais
c'est aussi une fabuleuse histoire
d'amour donc à découvrir dans nos salles
cette semaine
aussi 17 ou 18 49 haha ayaman contre 8,6
mais rasage
quatre hommes des unions des désunions
christian et françois ben aïm ont créé
bruno coeur insoumis une épopée
chorégraphique sur une partition
musicale d'ibrahim maalouf
extraits
[Musique]
allons
contre
un poteau en tête a confié à copenhague
[Musique]
le bonheur n'est pas toujours là où on
le pense mais il est accessible à tous
audrey à couilles
isabelle paillot et florent servan
schreiber vous propose de le cultiver en
qu'il faut regarder
je suis lancé manche la mer et je suis
professeur de bonheur professeurs avec
un e je suis audrey akroune et je suis
psychothérapeute la psychologie positive
c'est con pour tout le monde
bonjour je suis à ben fayot et je suis
danseuse étoile
[Musique]
non je déconne je suis psychologue wash
ma gueule
ensemble nous avons monté la fabrica
leaf la ferme à qatif c'est une
conférence sur le bonheur un sourire ou
un mannequin un concert maintenant celui
de françois morel le comédien chanteur
et chroniqueur rend hommage au music
hall
extraits françois faire un disque que
c'est bien mais un moment donné c'est
pas suffisant on te gentil tu veux les
mots croisés d'accord mais enfin il faut
faire parler de toi je n'ai pas moi les
rockstars sachets des trucs de dingue ça
descend les escaliers à motocyclette ça
détruit des chambres d'hôtel ça fait le
buzz
[Musique]
plus tard je réponds pied rugbyman aux
acteurs dervis qui tourne c'est la fin
de cette huile culture merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve mercredi
prochain
[Musique]
nous